rated M for Mature  things aren't going well at I in Africa  but house Forrester is nothing if not  resilient the you recall Lord foresters  last words to you he said the North  Grove must never be lost indeed and you  must find it Gallatin  all of you show your respect to Grif  while being my men will take our place  in your [ __ ] unless you think you in  your army could stop me  we can't live with them  Soylent our hops that means we have to  count on Asha and mirror I hope you will  at least agree with me that our  handmaiden should know their place and  that place is not with my brother  my family needs me I have to do whatever  I can't help  you have a good head for business Emira  it it'd be terribly disappointing to see  it on the end of the pike  first chance you get to have known  believe the night's watch behind the  nice ones execute men who deserves why  are you helping me help each other  that's both hides make no mistake  I'm still the Lord if I run and I